[Musique]
samedi 2h du matin nous sommes à la
marmite ou halles de rungis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la marmite c'était un tout petit bistrot
de tables des chaises louis de la grande
truanderie aux anciennes halles de paris
il y a trois ans
et à peine entré le diable s'est éloigné
dans la petite lumière du matin litres
et le définit le diable comme un petit
chariot à deux roues il sert à
transporter des caisses ou des sacs
depuis des années il a quatre roues et
un moteur mais il est resté l'instrument
du porteur l'emblème de ce monde mouvant
bruyant grouillant des halles
[Musique]
la pochette ou titre
or bien qu'on persiste à penser quand on
dit les halles à la rue du louvre à
saint-eustache
depuis trois ans elles sont ici alignés
le long de ces voies de chemin de fer ou
des trains complets qui viennent de
boulogne d'avignon amène directement la
marchandise aux portes des pavillons et
ce désintérêt ou on les tient fait
nouvelle gamme nous a semblé injuste car
les gestes les bruits le son des voix
ce sont bien les halles qu'on y retrouve
les halles tout court
[Musique]
3 heures du matin le pavillon de la
marée
nous sommes sur le carreau le carreau
c'est tout simplement ce vaste espace
central où les grossistes sont répartis
dans un désordre soigneusement calculés
oui
il
ban
ça parle
ces grossistes pour beaucoup ce sont les
anciens mandataires les seigneurs des
anciennes halles ils ont tenu à
reconstruire dans ce pavillon
ultramoderne leurs carreaux d'autrefois
en gros ils n'ont rien voulu changer
en colère des gens que
l'expéditeur m'avait volé sur la qualité
presque à meylan
transforme totalement la couleur tout ce
qui est rouge devient broye
saban des couleurs
correspond pas à la du jeu
pour trois quarts et l'éclairage par
alors vous normal
voulait supprimer
comment ça a été décidé le plan
et bien et
une consultation de professionnels
pour l'avoir il faut pas trop se
plaindre parce qu'ils ont bien que de ce
qu'on a dit
ils ont consulté d'une part les
mandataires qui étaient enfermés dans
leur grille à paris qui avait cette
habitude de carreaux et les gens de
l'extérieur qui re insisté pour avoir
des boutiques
je ne sais pas c
avait surtout l'habitude de travailler
comme ça alors ça les aurait beaucoup
changé de travail et eau pendant
regardez leurs habitudes mais enfin ils
ont plus perdu un petit peu de clientèle
par bordeaux c'est pas chez moi je
trouve à vous dire seul 950
vous avez noté le mot-clé habitude un
mot sacré pour le vendeur
en fait je veux
j'y reviens
si j'en ai
quand je vais vous dire pourquoi je veux
dire si j'en fais c'est parce que s'il
se trouve pas un sentiment chez besoin
se fait rien du tout pour ne pas fermer
des 107 rue tous
les gros poissons qui mangent harold
beaulieu ya pas au cabillaud et a pas
moufek des sols
jamais
grandes rigoles d'un sentiment je vais
perdre
vous à tort comme enjeu
c'est fragile la vente une lumière de
plus ou de moins
du beaulieu qui manquent alors on se
raccroche aux habitudes
c'est comme ces conversations c'est pas
fonctionnel pour un sou mais trouvait
donc mieux pour garder les clientèles
vous avez un concurrent féroce on a
écrit quand même temps c'était votre
votre ennemi mais c'est mon ami de la
doua qu'elle apparaît
septième en concurrent féroce battons
tous les jours
vous battez sont un terrain au bâton sur
la terre 2 - comment
avec déployer les qualités
nancy 5 ans à moi ah non c'est vous qui
avaient des chiffons moi j'en suis
certain bon alors je deviens 6,50 m
la revue a mon avis tu nous as fait
d'avoir vu quant au bruit en face d une
chose qui regardent le client est roi
je veux remettre à l'époque le client
est roi mais ça n'empêche pas de le
malmener le mystérieux d'un jeu très
ancien et qui n'a guère changé
gaborit une caisse
m.fillon de là
de bons dans le costume de tutu saâd
échauffent touche oui tu travailles des
galères là
qu'est-ce que
9 55 boîte de 5 et 10 passes le
mais leurs plumeaux il reste un gros tas
[Musique]
par là il veut en avoir lors des
canicules la seule temps le patois s'ils
s'étaient passés aux enchères salle des
ventes
mais c'est à dire
clients selon la quantité selon iliad
est passé de commerciaux qui font qu'on
a intérêt à vendre pas cher un jour
parce que il a acheté cher la veille
trop cher au coeur
une politique un état de grande détresse
est très humain comme système finalement
sa dépendance aux 6,5 m
c'est un soldat et un autre plus cher
enfin je me suis même pas là dedans
l'iedom choquant et sa saga de nbc 950
etc sinon j'aurais pu faire
on essaye on apprend qu'en voulant voler
et comme souvent le numéro 104 losc
après la vente est plus difficile parce
que maintenant les gardiennes acheter ce
dont ils ont besoin
alors qu'à paris on a on réussisse à
leur vendent eux-mêmes ce qu'ils
n'avaient pas besoin les attirer
pourquoi parce qu'ils étaient nerveux
crispé on ne pouvait pas leur place de
parking il avait il avait il avait
tourné pour une demi heure avant de
trouver une place
il arrivait à la vente n'hésitait pas
content hésiter hargneuse était méchant
même des fois se mettait un mouvement
une ambiance et ça nous permettait je
vous dis de leur vendre ce qu'ils
voulaient pas bien souvent parce que
notre métier c'est de vendre ce que veut
pas le client
un client qui est qui est un peu excité
on peut on peut lui vendre les biens
rythme qui est pris plus riche et la
plus mal d'un seul coup on le braque sur
un truc qui dimanche s'est peut être
intéressant il n'a peut-être pas le
temps de réfléchir comme il faut et on
lui vend
hall est rien le marché le meilleur
possible et le plus confus et le plus
inconfortable possible étrange principe
d'économie de marché que gilles à sa
façon nous confirme
mais cette fois sans moi peut-être d
mais ce n'est pas roger spécifiques tant
pis
transformant la profession
lorsque en fait
les choses se reproduisent à peu près
comme
simplement il ya plus de place c'est
plus moderne
deux possibilités
on dit justement là
place plus communs très facile plus
pratique en trottant prévenu circulation
nous
surprenant de voir l'animal
que ça représente
au travers dans tous les sens
alors ça il ya rien à faire on peut
essayer d
le règlement des ça c'est toi débat
d'après m
c'est quand m
c'est comme la place
d'où trois fois plus de place qu elle
est déjà en allemand
non
ça dépend si en vendée
on enfin
il n'y a pas tellement plus de poissons
à londres c'est encore moi c'est comme
ça c'est incompréhensible et sens unique
ça jamais dans les allées est impossible
de
changer faire espionner sens unique et
les respecte un jour deux jours
troisième ne respecte pas pourquoi ça
pourrait être très bien étudié très bien
prévu bien fonctionné
impossible a pris à bail
dès qu'ils sont là on peut pas leur
mettre un agent police chaque coin à une
heure du matin
et puis au fond
c'est cette merveilleuse ordonnancement
peut-être
nabors trépasse pour voulu faire
apporter
non il va ce système d qui est pas plus
mauvais
[Musique]
merveilleuse ordonnancement contre
système d si c'est là un des signes de
notre temps cette dame aux gros bonnets
de laine illustre bien c'est une gare 2
chaque détail 1 en effet effectue ses
achats chez des grossistes différents et
les regroupe sur un emplacement
surveillé par une garde heures aux
halles de paris
ce système était indispensable à cause
de la presse du manque d espace du
stationnement impossible
mais dans le merveilleux ordonnancement
de rungis avec l'été le nom des
pavillons les parkings un peu partout il
n'y avait évidemment pas de gars 2 prévu
à l'organigramme
elle était donc resté entre la rue
montorgueil et la rue des halles mais il
a fallu bien vite aller les rechercher
justifiant ainsi le célèbre dicton pas
de gare deux pas de poisson
[Musique]
6h du matin la marée mais toi son
carreau ferme ses portes la nuit fait
place aux gens dans les bars bruyamment
dans ce métier les mareyeurs partant
rencontrer les bo f montant savez
lebedev sont les beurre fromage et ils
tiennent leur marché entre 8h et 11h du
matin
à la chaleur des gestes et des mots
entendus depuis toujours va succéder la
froideur des avenues vide
à force d'être large
on ne pouvait aménager l'espace à la
fois pour l'homme et pour le véhicule
l'homme debout occupe un demi mètre
carré le véhicule plusieurs mètres
carrés l'homme était battu davance et
par lui-même et puisse pas lui qui avait
exigé de pouvoir circuler aisément
rapidement de n'importe quel point
n'importe quel autre enfermé dans sa
coquille de métal cet homme automobile
sept hommes de notre temps est il au
moins de près ou de loin satisfait les
premiers jours c'est un drôle de choc a
ses points sauf chez nous a fait une
drôle d'impression ont été perdus un
truc
enfin les premiers temps qu'on à 8,6 à
fait l'impression d'une caserne
si vous avez eu à donner des idées pour
faire un vice
vous auriez fait autrement c'est une
rotation
on n'est pas étranger cerveau toute
façon j c était pour être la ville est
que c'est pareil s'est fait fort il fait
obligé d'y venir pour garder notre
boulot mais
avoir des idées les idées sont bien il
dit il a sans doute raison qu'il entre
nous il conçut un agissent différence en
béton sans rocade sens vide car les
données sont là à tangible vingt-cinq
mille voitures par jour quatre marches
et un cinquième pour bientôt le
développement des entrepôts de la gare
routière des zones industrielles des
zones annexe du marché national européen
et tout cela à grand renfort de voitures
de camions de train alors alors nous
voulons des changements que nous
n'aimons pas enfin pas tout de suite
saluons au passage notre petit diable
dont on voit bien qu'il est tout à fait
à sa place dans ce pavillon fourmilière
il a même amélioré avec son moteur la
souplesse d'utilisation de son
arrière-grand-père le chariot à bras
vous voyez bien qu'on se fait au progrès
saluons aussi les derniers témoins de
ces vieilles halles baroque et coloré
mais de ces halles aussi assez durs pour
avoir laissé ses traces là sur leur
visage
sans doute est-ce le signe de ce temps
ci la découverte de la merveilleuse
lenteur de l'homme de cette prudence
qu'on eût dit paysanne il y a 20 ans et
qui est tout bonnement qu'humaine de ce
frein que l'homme mais sans le vouloir
vraiment à ses propres entreprises le
rythme commence toujours par leur gré
c'était un quart d'heure s'était jamais
nous bouffer comme on n'est pas ici
j'avais plus les uns sur les autres
moi on a vu que
et pour celui qui à la longue on leur
enlevait tout à l'inversé
concours aspects de sa gueule qu'il a
lancé et vouloir gagner ça on est loin
de la région on est loin de la rue la
rue d'ulm qu'est ce qui avait réduit le
cochon était mort km2 industrielles
porteuses d'un gène j la grosse
différence c'est que nous on l'était
dehors tu n'importe quel temps où il
pleuvait les anciennes halles avec gl
domicile il ya plus de soupe à l'oignon
à troyes de paris ont fait un petit peu
en étant les landes réparé une porte
c'est à l'heure ça vous plaît pas ça
[Musique]
la porte là voilà c'est le péage un bien
vilain mot et ça beau n'être qu'un
paiement de parking
heureusement très inférieur à ce qu'ils
paient à paris sous plusieurs formes
le péage reste impopulaire on n'est même
pas rentré chez soi comme sur une
autoroute
l'aménagement de l'espace ayant été fait
pour l'homme automobile
rien n'a été négligé la dispatching de
la circulation 2000 rungis et les vannes
sont surveillés qui donne accès à
l'autoroute fierté les régies soit à
cause des vingt-cinq mille véhicules qui
entrent ou qui sortent chaque jour de
rungis il a fallu en effet doubler cette
autoroute entre le marché parie et la
construction avait terminé complètement
en neuf mois en standard dans le marché
notre diable fait son boulot de chaque
jour charger ou décharger le client dont
il vient d'amener ou dont il va emmener
la marchandise sous son entière
responsabilité
au départ de rungis il était quatre ou
cinq cents ils ne sont plus guère que la
moitié parce qu'avec les facilités de
stationnement beaucoup de détails en
charge tous des charges même
change rien à dire il faut savoir le
faire puis c'est un échec quand même qui
demande beaucoup de soin on avait pu le
point n'importe quelle marchandise
n'importe comment la patate c'est ça se
manipule une certaine façon alors que
quand on est transporté indium le
programme complet de fraises ou de
cerises là il ya quand même une certaine
délicatesse dont en exécution du travail
voire la tête pour le faire et puis les
bras à la fois il en faut beaucoup parce
que celle ci avait dit qu'il est quand
même assez pénible qui est physique on
voit des porteurs arriver à faire 15 16
heures 17 heures dans mon travail au
travail disons deux forces
j'aimerais bien monsieur voilà
j'aimerais mieux pour expliquer pourquoi
pourquoi il est si important que le
porter je dois travailleurs indépendants
qui ne soient pas sous la tutelle de
quelque chose ou quelqu'un oui réécoutez
site une question de liberté at on dit à
goûter où ça c'est quelque chose de
formidable c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
peut pas oublier
on a toujours travaillé comme des gens
libres de faire leur travail
alors passons en convention en
respectant les normes bien entendu en
respectant le client qui nous confient
travail m'enfin avec une liberté tels
que on ne peut pas dans mon pool d'avoir
nulle part face et être une liberté
totale voulait d'urgence canada les
anciennes halles sinon non ici on est
est un tas de contraintes de subir mal
bon gré mal gré un concile but pouvait
dire que ce passage des halles de paris
à régis s'est pas bien passé pour les
porter absolument pas je crois c'est bon
c'est mon sentiment que l'esprit
libertaire du porteur a été avec ce
déménagement
jean bayle france un des ménages un
déménagement m'a personnellement
j'appelle ça une déportation
je vous en ai pas du tout
est ce que ça veut dire que la
protection de porter est condamnée à
brève échéance mais pourquoi on ne sent
pas on ne sent pas la nécessité de
absolue du porteur ici et puis les
tracasseries administratives
je marchais lui-même ce que ça mange
avec les mauvais il est mauvais par les
messins plus arranger tout ça je te
prête tellement d'espoir j'avais
beaucoup d'espoir jusqu'à ces derniers
temps puis à remettre sans cesse sur le
chantier des questions qui auraient pu
être solutionnée dès le départ on peut
on ne peut plus croire en de petits
croire à des possibilités
je me bats toujours mais c'est
pratiquement sans espoir
[Musique]
on pourra pourtant difficilement se
passer des porteurs nous ait mis un peu
plus tard monsieur debout président du
comité de défense des porteurs de rungis
peut-être at-il bien cacher un peu plus
d'espoir qu'il ne dit le porteur c'est
le plus petit citoyen à part entière de
rungis indépendant il me l'a dit à
l'autre extrémité voici le grossiste lui
c'est monsieur docu six jeunes une des
plus grandes et des plus vieilles
maisons des halles
il a installé un gros ordinateur dont il
a la charge
nous réalisons les trois heures quand
vous étiez enfant vous aviez envie de
travailler dans la maison familiale ou
non peut-être quand j'étais d'opter au
stade où tous les enfants ou envie de
faire la même chose que leur père mais
pas au delà de 10 en 10 12 ans c'était
fini le métier n'est pas un n'est pas
très reluisant d'ailleurs on voit bien
nous avons beaucoup de mal à attirer des
jeunes et pourquoi une
véritablement une crise de structures
dans ce métier c'est à dire que tout
tout l'accroissement de la consommation
se fait au profit des formes modernes de
distribution vous même ce transfert vous
a poussé à rentrer dans la maison
paternelle
non disons que je voulais je voulais
être présent au moment où se
au moment où on distribuer de nouvelles
cartes pour une nouvelle génération
puisqu'on a abandonné d un groupe en
pied d'immeuble dans le centre de paris
pour repartir non avec un nouvel outil à
rungis il fallait être là au moment où
on distribue les cartes c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt comme ça car que rungis est
un peu le sacrifice d'une génération et
au bénéfice d'une autre d'une nouvelle
nous bénéficions ne sais pas quoi
au bénéfice d'un inconnu complet le
marché or on ne sait pas où vous ne
faites pas de prospective vous ne savez
pas ce que sera raji sous votre
profession dans 50 ans on fait de la
prospective mai
nouveau répond que simplement dans dix
ans on ignore tout à fait ce que sera la
profession on arrive à raisonner à deux
ou trois ans dans ce métier après c'est
vraiment beaucoup trop flou on ne peut
plus être sûr de rien il ya vraiment
trop d'inconnues vous avez raison d'être
un certain monsieur du pij
l'équation est devenue trop complexe
mais comme nous l'a dit votre propre
père il faudra toujours que les gens
mangent des fruits et des légumes et
donc qu'ils viennent ici où nous sommes
et comme ils viennent la grève prendra
il faudra bien elle prend déjà ici et là
haut nil un bistrot autour d'une piste
de 421
et puis il y aussi les raisons plus
sérieuse d'être moins pessimistes celle
de monsieur bretons président les
grossistes européens brown qui a
constaté à plusieurs reprises aux états
unis que le marché traditionnel
reprenait de plus en plus d'importance
[Musique]
de rage et des difficultés que je
constate dans tous les marchés français
qu'ils soient marché d'intérêt national
ou simplement marché de gros
traditionnelle et que je constate encore
plus dans des pays voisins comme
l'allemagne
l'angleterre où d'autres pays donc c'est
la profession en général qui est qui et
qui est bouleversée qui est bousculé
c'est pas c'est pas seulement la
profession de rungis alors comment
comment expliquez vous cette réaction
disons d'inquiétude crainte
d'incompréhension des gens qui ont
émigré se dire de des allergies sont
inquiets de l'avenir parce que
d'abord ils n'étaient pas tellement
préparés que peut-être à partir de mots
ils ont accepté l'idée du transfert ils
se sont fait peut-être trop d'illusions
sur ce qui allait devenir possible
beaucoup ont quitté les halles à regret
et puis d'un seul coup ce solide rebond
batailler
je fais le saut j'entreprends une trois
nouvelles villes nouvelles démarches et
puis les difficultés qu'ils ont
rencontrées les ont immédiatement
heurtée à l'heure actuelle l'impression
que j'ai c'est qu'ils ont peur de
l'instrument qu'ils ont entre les mains
ils savent pas très bien le si c'est cet
instrument qui est responsable de leurs
difficultés
ainsi au contraire ils sauront s'en
servir pour pouvoir s'adapter à
l'évolution qui se présente elle
l'instrument relais le mot comme
instrument chirurgical
il faut le temps le temps d'apprendre à
s'en servir et dans le pavillon du bo
est fou nous sommes l'apprentissage a
été rude un grossiste sur deux a disparu
en termes d'économie ça s'appelle la
concentration mais les bénéfices n'ont
pas augmenté en proportion
ici aussi on est inquiet
alors ligue charme de la main
de 60 n'auriez ceux là même qui ont cru
à rungis qui ont mis le paquet ont
essuyé des bois même s'il continue et
moi sommes partis d'un seul coup de
paris avec les vieilles habitudes du
marché à peu près bien les traditionnels
pour se retrouver d'un seul coup dans un
nouveau lieu de travail n'ayant
pratiquement aucune ressemblance avec
lens hier et ça en l'espace de 48 heures
j'ai installé un petit système
d'informatique ce qui était tout à fait
nouveau dans la profession j'ai voulu le
faire le jour de l'ouverture de rungis
en dix ans tant qu'à faire puisque on
change tout allons-y carrément et ça a
été le folklore je me rappelle des
premiers jours où les caisses n'était
pas finie ou en fait qu'est-ce j'avais
d'être est d une sorte de traite de
tréteaux avec des planches par dessus et
des billets de banque qui frôlait etc et
en même temps vous marchez un ordinateur
pour la première fois c'était le vrai
folklore bon c'est ça c'est le pense et
ce que on peut extrapoler est ce qu'on
peut dire que un marché que vous aviez
imaginé au départ
extrêmement différent du marché des
halles de paris est finalement resté
très proche et qui refusent certains
moyens modernes comme l'ordinateur et
qui refusent qui également profondément
des changements il y à une partie de la
profession qui a en effet est arrivé un
phénomène de rejet
je voulais apporter non seulement ce
service informatique pour votre
expérience pour avoir mes chiffres mais
surtout pour mettre au service d'un
certain nombre des clients pour les
aider à déterminer les
les marges leurs marges mais elle a aidé
à mieux c'est à mieux suivre leur
problème s'apercevoir les produits qui
était rentable ce qui n'était pas en
fonction même du linéaire de la place
qu'ils occupaient dans leur magasin et
c'est assez curieux parce qu'il ya trois
ans est un véritable phénomène de rejet
comme vous disiez tout à l'heure même de
la part de ses clients
et maintenant il y en a certains
glissent et demain je pourrais pas
l'abandonner parce que maintenant nous
commençons à en ressentir le besoin de
même les vendeurs par exemple qui ont
été au début très réticents et qui ont
eu du mal à se mettre à l'âge de
l'informatique sont venus en délégation
veut dire qu'il n'est pas question vous
abandonniez maintenant nous commente
nous en avons besoin nous avait habitués
à lui les caisses des bords de des beaux
alignements prévu pour assurer la
meilleure circulation et la plus grande
rapidité possible car s'il arrive qu'une
nouvelle habitude celle de l'ordinateur
chasse l'ancienne pour le reste on
s'accroche on se raccroche aux
traditions le panier semble faire la
nique à la comptabilité mécanographie
coûts informatiques du premier étage
le meilleur bureau c'est une caisse
debout au milieu du bruit je sens la
vente au bruit disait l'un d'eux et le
client grâce au ciel continue à
considérer que l'important dans le
fromage c'est de goûter
[Musique]
chantal et télé qui avaient été
installés pour annoncer les cours
assainir le marché
elle a été purement et simplement refusé
gêne à la vente ont dit les grossistes
unanime
en attendant de servir d'instrument de
liaison entre les marchés nationaux et
un jour européen
elle passe des petites annonces mais le
plus bel exemple de rejet c'est celui ci
la bourse sur ce qui devait arriver des
wagons qui aurait été achetée en bloc
par de gros acheteurs réunis dans le
bâtiment à côté dans une bourse aux
fruits et légumes on l'a confié
l'opération aux grossistes qui n'ont pas
su et guerre voulue semble-t-il s'en
servir le frein à fonctionner pour le
bien ou pour le marin le temps donnez
nous le temps répète inlassablement les
hommes de régis
autre prévision démenti au bénéfice des
hommes cette fois le marché aux fleurs
que l'on croyait voué à la concentration
comme les autres ici l'instrument a
étouffé ni les traditions mille
personnes
j'ai débuté chez mes parents à l'âge de
12 et à je suis à mon compte depuis 1947
un geste ça a été un gros changement oh
là ça a été terrible
le rite toujours se plaindre pour calmer
les dieux même si on doit expliquer
ensuite que les choses ne se passe pas
si mal
j'avais 15 ans mais là même qui suit
l'homme
pourquoi est ce que ce marché ne s'est
pas concentré comme les autres
ah ça c'est une forme
nous avons une forme de commerce qui n'a
rien à voir avec les autres grossistes
37,1 tout du moins chez nous c'est la
multitude de vendeurs
et d'acheteurs qui fait vivre le marché
cette année
août a gelé
il ya beaucoup de petites affaires et
qui lisent pas bien qui travaille très
bien il y à 200 grossistes qui occupent
de 8 mètres carrés à 80 mètres carrés
la doyenne madame gauthier vérane la 82
ans je me fais plus que je faisait
autrefois
moi vous savez 20 à 25 30 pagny par jour
ça me suffit largement j'ai des clients
court ça me suffit vous ne tenez pas
vous agrandir leur il faudrait cochon un
projet les communes que je crois que
quelqu'un je pourrais pas faire tout
seul comprenez ce serait pas possible
vous préféré gagner ce dont vous avez
besoin a plus ça me suffit
je gagne de bonnes vacances ça me suffit
et vous pensez que rungis vous permettra
de rester une petite affaire marchand
est l'affairé se rouler vous comprenez
pas ce que j'ai de bons d'expéditeur
j'ai de bons clients qui payent bien
l'affairé cen et j'espère quand même
l'avant je ferai quand je me retirerai
c'est peut-être pas demain la veille
mais enfin ça viendra tant que je me
sens en forme et que je suis en bonne
santé que j'ai toutes mes facultés que
voulez vous que je fasse prendre les
flûtes
je suis à un âge maintenant ou une
l'inertie vous savez n'est pas bonne
mais alors là malgré tout j'ai la
distraction et le jeu fait du sport un
roman mais paris continue ça va comme ça
savoir limiter ses moyens à ses besoins
dit la sage madame verra monsieur
gautier lui pense à l'avenir au marché
national et même européen
cette semaine nous avons eu la visite
d'un importateur belge qui sont
intéressés certainement par la
marchandise qui suit le marché parisien
vous êtes optimiste toujours toujours
mais par nécessité ou pas même un
poireau nom parfait et je pense que
l'avenir me down
[Musique]
il arrive à rungis que l'avenir soit
caché par des embouteillages digne du
meilleur passé en apparence seulement
car ils ne durent pas il y a trop
d'espacés
[Musique]
devant cette situation un homme pourrait
se mettre en colère qui a tout prévu
pour que ne puisse pas y avoir
d'embouteillages c'est le patron de
rungis libère bout il ne le fait pas car
depuis dix ans l'époque des études
exploratoires le planificateur qu'il
était a progressivement cédé la place à
l'empirisme qu'il est devenu le point
cyb la circulation voulait que tout
passe par c'était cette grande rocade
qui fait tout le tour du marché et que
c'est une rando raid qu'on ne puisse pas
croisé perpendiculairement on avait donc
aménager des refuges vous voyez qui
s'entend en forme de diabolo et qui
devait renvoyer la circulation
transversale dans le sens longitudinal
mais l'élément humain était plus fort on
n'a pas empêché pendant longtemps ce
qu'ils voulaient traverser de traverser
carrément en face
bien que ce soit interdit il a fallu
donc pour leur apprendre qu'il fallait
s'injecter dans le sens de la
circulation de la rocade a ajouté cette
espèce de bordures que vous voyez là qui
n'est pas très belle mais qui a été
qu'ils arrivent été suffisante pour
montrer aux gens ce qu'il fallait faire
il est certain que les usagers de rungis
répugne à observer des règles qui sont
en avance sur le temps actuel est qu'ils
ne comprennent pas
il faut se souvenir que tout de même
la circulation a été pensé à rungis pour
ce qui va se passer dans une vingtaine
d'années
voilà bien le dilemme construire pour
l'immédiat
hu était absurde construire pour dans 20
ans ce n'est pas très vivable
cependant si elle est suffisamment pour
qu'on puisse après les actions
retardataires dans l'homme sur
l'instrument apercevoir les premières
réactions de l'instrument sur l'homme
les grandes facilités qui sont offertes
aux détaillants permet de mettre en
compétition plus facilement les
grossistes les uns par rapport aux
autres quand on le faisait dans les
halles pour les difficultés de
circulation ont obligé les acheteurs à
aller toujours au même endroit et à
avoir à faire à mes temps à une dizaine
de vendeurs
il y avait peu d'acheteurs qui faisait
tout les ages c'était impossible
tandis qu'ici presque tous les acheteurs
font toutes les halles de rungis et peut
voir tous les vendeurs tous les
grossistes et discuter les prix avec eux
donc ils ont en face d'eux une plus
grande quantité de vendeurs beaucoup
plus grande que dans les halles donc le
pouvoir de négociation du détaillant a
été accrue par rapport à ce qu'il était
dans les halles au détriment du
grossiste d'ailleurs c'est la revanche
du détaillant david et goliath mais ici
larmes de david n'est pas la fraude
c'est la petit cycle est
principes tactiques l'adversaire est
puissant mais fixe attaché à son poste
il faut être léger et très mobile
ça va quand go
à lire
cette richesse
poussée d american des us et coutumes
leurs gardes du corps
oui il y en a 2 tient
quoi
où l'on mettait un sac
st gallois
je
ce sont les combines dahmane hunter g
correa c'est légal et les combines bonne
acheteurs pouvaient alors ça il faut
ouvrir l'oeil et le bon il faut aller
vite vous m'avez dit il ya des preuves
pour les mavs il faut prendre des
décisions rapidement d'autant qu'ils
approuvent marchandises
il faut faire vite il faut pas attendre
qu'elles sont amiens il ya des fois en
dix minutes il ya plus d'un micro il ya
du travail il faut au moment des cerises
ça m'était arrivé d'arrivée de de
réfléchir trop longtemps faire 20 m et
puis de revenir à cet effet nous y en
avait fait son point de vue sont
cabossés temps mais doit y arriver ce
matin
moi tu fais confiance à 100 150 cd
caisse de combien
on m'avait dit il faut attendre
aujourd'hui moi j'ai des haricots
acheter jouer d acheter en mon talent
parce que vient pas de vente alors les
prix risquent de baisser ou de payer
haricots ou huit cent vingt loups 900
ballon va les payer cinq ou six ans on
pourra les ventes d'autant moins cher
est ce que tu voulais madame ben oui
mais j'ai besoin de rien est ce que les
vendeurs sont contents que vous ayez des
vélos un sage interdire sur votre avis
ils sont pas dans l'intérieur qu'est ce
que tu en penses tu as you go si les
vendeurs sont heureux qu'on ait des
vélos ce n'est pas une situation
peut-être un petit peu parce que quand
ils nous disent le bti vous désirez et
brille à la gamme comme on dit et on
fout le camp
et souvent on n'y a pas alors le gars
qui sait qu'on achète 20 30 50 10 ans
et bien si il va sentir partout il y en
a qui achète 100 billion nous on était
tout petit à côté il ya des gros qui
achète 200 billets s'ils disent les
bêtises les vendeurs ses vinyles et
gravité
les tomates ses deux numéros 8 cellules
numéro 4 d'abord du cat le 5 je te fais
je veux un pour toi là bas il s'en veut
deux mois déjà
et c'est bon
voilà des orages ailleurs la plus grosse
est ce que vous vendez de la même façon
à rungis chorale
a rungis est beaucoup plus
pourquoi passent plus mes clients sont
pacifiques
vous avez des clients qui ne reviennent
pas aux clients viennent et reviennent
mais pour davantage en vélo en vélo oui
d'ailleurs le vélo il fait beaucoup
beaucoup ce nuisible
après larmes simple oscille armes
sophistiquées le vélo équipé en chef de
monsieur boyer
sont déjà d'accord enfin 17 francs sera
mieux pour moi avec le diamant d'accord
vous enfin avec un deal le marché de
thomas levet qui est ferme et enfin 17
francs ou me fait 100 colis s'ils ont
partagé la poire en 2007 50 sait rien
faire
bon bah écoutez je vous en prendre une
centaine vont vous marquerez sans les
tuche et brunes et vous remarquerez
aussi j'ai oublié de vous dire les
citrons chez sodi fruits avec les
clémentines chez sodi fruits monsieur
boyer a créé une centrale d'achat qui
regroupe plusieurs détaillants un
principe simple plus on achète moins on
paie d'arriver sur les halles
on profite de la vie dans la baisse et
des coûts et dans l'intérêt à passer par
moi parce que moi que j'arrive toujours
trouvé des prix très intéressants et des
fois meilleur même met en marche et
quand frontières alors les achats sont
reçus les commandes de taux d'achat sont
reçus par téléphone et par téléphone son
nid sur une feuille d'achat c'est ce que
fait monsieur ce que fait monsieur et
après elles sont ventilés et chaque
article et ventilés sur le feuille
d'achat
regroupez vous savez que vous avez
autant de quantité partie quartiers
parlent un peu si j'ai de satan div
les 220 livres sont marqués sur une
faille et je me présente chez le
négociant et je discute avec ses 200
colis dans bible le prix et la qualité
de la marquise que j'ai acheté quand
vous partez en vélo avec notre monétaire
et quand j'ai acheté la marchandise
je pense je transmets
déballant plh t les endives telle maison
bon vous marquerez les clémentine corse
chez avec prime les clémentines coach et
à une prime vous avez reçu vous
marquerez et les clémentines corse chez
l&v prime mais je ne tremblait pas le
fruit avec mon sac effectif que je n'ai
pas le football parce que les six gens
seront faits alors j'ai un autre
appareil là j'ai un pocket memo dans
lequel tout doucement janvier sur le
prix et que je retourne au bureau après
pour savoir le peu que j'ai payé
fonctionne votre appareil voilà par
exemple j'ai acheté aujourd'hui des
envies vous et payez d'offres en 42
francs 45 à la salle arrive à répéter
ces discussions d'abord malgré les
gadgets radio électronique des fruits et
légumes ont précieusement conservé leurs
traditions écoutez irène car dans les
betteraves ont été super bagarre de la
[Musique]
dette intérieure est très belle
alors je t'en mettre en rogne
tout ce que tu veux et m'a fait m
voyez alors le plus juste prix est
d'accord emma qu'un sert de chez paul
dépêche-toi il est pressé il reçut alors
voir vaud l'ain merci paul nous avons en
suivant les mains tachées de 30 corps
dont miss très souvent parce que dès
qu'il ya 30 ans présente la betterave
aussi bien qu'on arrive à la barre alors
il faut leur expliquer pour une
brillance à la dame est un premier pas
tant leur prénom de salades il faut
faire ça pour leur montrer la salade
vont bien leur expliquer bien leur
montrer et se jouant mal à l'avaler
tuberie la ville alors j'aime la bella
ici la très belle à saumur des seize se
sent très bien elle est très très très
très belle si j'ai des grosses 12-12
là-bas très belle elle bat 16 cents
aussi l'appel elle est très tôt mais
suzanne travail à libérer mme cardon
depuis un tiers de siècle
nous les avons trouvés dans un film
tourné sur les vieilles halles il ya
déjà quatre ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
et pourtant
ce sont des mots d'amour
l'amour c'est ma chanson préférée
la chanteuse
le mans
[Musique]
et
elle est bien loin la rue du louvre et
ce petit bistrot et vous êtes un client
par exemple marchande est bon vous dis
viens je te paye un café mais bon on
allait boire un café puis dans sur ce
club on parlait de travail alors je
vendais tout de suite par exemple
j'avais vu la marchandise alors je
voudrais tout de suite sur en buvant un
café potito il s'en aller mais c'est
très rare quand on allait dans les cafés
de faire notre travail allait rester sur
place tout au moins nous les femmes on
n'avait pas le temps d'aller boire tout
le temps dans les cafés d'avoir une
femme c'était pas son genre un homme
vont ils aller voir un café avec un
copain ou n'importe quand mais prend du
coup on n'aurait pas fini de boire alors
est ce que le genre des gens est en
train de changer à rungis des gens ont
été changés depuis la même chose et là
même camaraderie on arrive on travaille
pour samba on dit bonjour puis c'est
fini
le vocabulaire change a woman a déjà
changé depuis très longtemps même dans
les halles centrales
le vocabulaire était beaucoup moins
grossier s'allume au moins une vingtaine
d'années quand j'ai débuté mois en 1930
c'était assez grossier mais après par la
suite assez bien amélioré ma quinzième
boire bien passé quelque chose mme aka
bien là et les transports comment vous
faites c'est très longue or vous savez
c'est pas marrant moi je vienne
pierrefitte jacquard de remarcher je
monte un étage en dessin étage prendre
un jeune et pour un quart d'heure j'en
prends un train le métro de métro change
gare de l'est garde de lège laissant
pandit ali pour d'italie ce travers d'un
boulevard le boulevard je reprends le
debussy jeuland j'en ai pour une
demi-heure venait pour une heure trois
quarts eh bien vous savez il faut le
faire 35 km tous les jours
si mme yade je crois mixte qui m'a rendu
malade
c'est pas rigolo intervenir ils n'ont
rien fait pour les ouvriers sous
questions là ils ont fait beaucoup pour
les gros mais pas pour le voyez ça pour
nous voyons pas fait grand chose et vous
croyez que l'ambiance des halles
reviendra ici
renaîtra au non c'est pas possible au
non madame cardozo n'en reviendra qu'en
pensez vous chacun fait son travail il
faut qu'on affine et on s'en va tout et
on tousse on aura pu rentrer chez lui le
soir même car dont ils croient que c'est
possible
jamais l'ambiance des halles à paris ah
non il n'y aura pas l'ambiance de paris
re a quand même fait un bénin de faire
du radis berbie derby vient faire du
radis vient bien de faire du rabbi
c'est vrai madame suzanne
vous ça ne reviendra pas
la mémoire comme les photographies ne
retient que les moments heureux et les
moments heureux
il y en a eu beaucoup dans la jeunesse
irène cardon et suzanne et plus loin il
ya toujours un passé à passer que l'on
regrette et dont la mémoire de fix que
les instants comme celui ci où on sourit
aux photographes
et
[Musique]
cette apparition de notre diable dans la
nuit au marché des fruits et légumes se
fait rare aux anciennes halles tous
passé deux nuits à cause du
stationnement des embouteillages de la
circulation mais dans celle ci il ya de
la place et le travail de jour a conquis
droit de cité vivre normalement
travailler le jour
dormir la nuit c'est un des vrais succès
de rungis
[Musique]
bien sûr il y a toujours quelqu'un et
gros ou les petits acheteurs ou quelque
chose les conditions de températures
trop grande chaleur qui est faire
établir de temps en temps les horaires
de nuit
mais ce soir il semble bien que ce soit
la dernière ni les fruits et légumes
[Musique]
cette bascule maintenant
on a été on a été un bon bout de temps
on va faire elle aussi ans de sûreté
mais nous émeut pas grand monde
[Musique]
les gens ils descendent plus tard ils
descendent plus tard car en mettant à la
plus en plus fort
effects lui assure une fête
[Musique]
enfin un cerbère ça a beaucoup changé
les horaires je pensais la dernière nuit
pour quoi faire c'est l'année où l'avant
dernière après ça il y aura plus de nuit
à croire en tout cinq jours privés et
pourquoi on changerait horaire tout cas
à ces personnes je travaille la nuit la
nuit c'est pour faire dodo quand on fait
les plus belles du monde l'aimé elle les
plus modernes est mort on laisse les
gens dans nos relais est normale chez
vous aimez mieux vous regrettez pas les
nuits des halles en surprenant en sicile
je me suis dit oh vous savez bien beau
monde a longuement parlé l'autre fois
mais attendez voilà un exemple le
contact mouais son père je l' ai connu
voilà mais lille était clos il était
beau milieu d'un bain
quoi c'est plus ça maintenant ils
pensent avec son vélo 1,50 à l'heure là
je vois mais vous êtes content que ce
soit et dernière nuit quand même
obama fois et demie par semaine on nous
répond en hiver ça va mais les pc
vincennes près de paris
l'été dernier il a pas fallu revenir à
des nuits oui l'homme
c'est ça ils voudraient dormir la nuit
et en même temps ne pas perdre cette
chaude camaraderie de la nuit il invente
des outils pour aménager sa vie et quand
l'outil prétend diriger à l'excès cette
vie alors il le rejette ou le
transformer
g
[Musique]
on aurait entraîné
il y
o o
je pars ce sens là
[Applaudissements]
moi je
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
on